hey guys some time ago we promised you a
bunch of modern tools for this world of
mine and I'm happy to tell you that the
abbot is here
say hello to disrobe mine 2.0 so what
we'll be able to do those tools actually
first of all you'll be able to create a
brand-new scenarios where you can change
the weather conditions the chance of
being crated the duration of war and
many many more creating new things will
be also a feature that we were adding in
this update through the medicine tools
all the things you can imagine can be
actually transferred into game right now
of course we haven't forgotten about
crafting so that's why in the brand new
updates we'll be able to create your own
particular recipes gas are the next
category of items you will be able to
create in our game so if you have any
favorite install or absolute rifle or
maybe you want to recreate some real or
historic events now you will be able to
do it a lot but at least I think that
many we have been asking for from now on
you'll be able to add your own piece of
music to the game so it's been a
favorite trackers like that now it came
with a part of the game and that's all
for today I hope that you like the
changes that we introduced in this row
my 2.0 but be sure that's not the end of
the story for us because we are already
working on the brand new tools that will
be introduced in our community stay
tuned
you